You killed that woman and searched for their bodies in Istanbul for two and a half
hours 11
Why do you think why is it so easy to
kill women Because it's women's rights day for
this purpose But what
is yours? Selamunaleyküm I hope it's cold that Enes brother's Cad
pendistrep How is it ours but
now he is defending TV Fight rounds so many
girls We are the most  a lot of scotland a lot of weight in jail
Half we know how Boyfriend elective
course
Great God Ali Subway Surfers toino a
cold candle Selamunaleyküm Aleykümselam you
Fine thanks Thank you very much
Unfortunately, it's supposed to exist,
but
actually it doesn't exist.  Going to jail This is not the first and not the last
Listen like this every day
I bought a Turkish television every day,
for example, a woman is getting divorced, her husband
comes to her after years, she kills the woman,
it is such a right, I don't understand how she can find it herself,
I really don't understand her,
stop of her in your other meeting, I hope you
are, Uncle, where are you, hello, good
together, wifi Forgive 110 tennis Lava
Let's get the last taste of
lava, see if she's talking, last see if she's talking, very
morning, your smile All this woman
died
Yes, now the family has already lost a living being
, of course, it dies again.
I mean,
she ca
n't feed herself.
Look, God gave us all a life, you
got it  Does this take our souls Allah takes our lives
No one but Allah I will come
Is it our time Allah is entrusted
we have to have it
Is it a tablet from this address No this ate
Archery there is the sea Here check no no
fear Virgin Radio Live Life Arabia
previously very angry baby girls
alive  they were burying Nadir finspor
nesine.com then Baccarat Feel Angry
woman and they had many people that I
need look at the monument ourian track Texas
Blood Korean dirty or not your coffin and not
mass Mintan House please RSS YouTube
and this is ours a' this draw
if it wasn't sexy leave  If you want to
make peace with the women, don't try to
hurt them before you come here in a nice way, post your
photo
.  I was angry, do you know? The
prophet made a meal and the other prepared such
a meal  He's
eating the skewer, he's more jealous, brother,
he hit the ground
with
a
smack like that.
What does it mean?
he says at an, so
you don't have the right to get married.
I don't know the
name of
him.
I don't
want to die.
when you
stand behind it Yes,
so he didn't do anything, when you look at it, you stop.
You know
, when there is no remedy, there is no law, your man does
not let them in, they do not give an answer. There
is someone every day for him, stop film,
play Sait,
two questions Enis to the  most common
modification he drew quickly I hope
it's dirty it's a concert dirty sonexson
Selamunaleyküm move everyone